all right if you own a home
pay attention here listen up here's a
question have you paid your property
taxes
you probably should yeah
but you also need to pay attention to
this there's a form that'll be coming to
you in the mail maybe you already
received it and you need to pay
attention it's small you might throw it
away
but it's very important bianca holman is
here to explain exactly why you need to
fill it out and send it back
hey good morning john good morning
heather hopefully you've received that
tax cap abatement card in the mail it
can sometimes catch people off guard but
you need to return it as quickly as
possible to let the county know if the
current property is your primary
residence a rental or maybe it's
something else so homeowners should have
received the postcard regarding the tax
abatement the clark county assessor says
if the property is your primary
residence then your property taxes
cannot increase more than 3 percent from
what you paid in the previous year but
if it's a new home a new constructed
home the tax cap doesn't apply the first
year the new improvements have to set
the base for your taxes usually the
first year you're only paying taxes on
the land and with so many new folks here
in the area this may be a new task for
them
here in nevada and clark county we do
have a tax cap abatement program
that allows your taxes if it is your
primary residence to only increase no
more than three percent or up to eight
percent for any other properties over
the taxes that you paid in the previous
year not the value of your home but the
actual taxes paid in the previous year
so this is why it's so important that
you fill out that card and send it back
if the card's not returned you could
possibly be taxed at a higher rate which
is up to eight percent and to check the
amount that you're paying to make sure
that you're paying the right amount you
can visit the treasurer's page they have
a form there you fill out the
information and you can take care of
things there now sometimes again the
rate may be wrong and
in the next half hour we're going to
talk about how you can get that fixed
and by contacting the clark county
assessor so that's coming up in the next
half hour bianca holman live local now